[Music]
let's go to san antonio and
hi felicia what's up
hello
what are you up to
i'm at work but you know took a break
very very cool way to go
hey yeah so felicia is like my top three
favorite names of all time ever in the
history of the world so thank you for
having that name on my show today all
right so what's up
so my question for you is so my husband
um
comes from a very religious
family
um
was kind of like
you know was kicked out of his family
kind of brought back in um he's starting
therapy and he will be doing trauma
therapy
and i
probably walk that line where i ask too
many questions okay
so i'm trying to find like where is that
balance uh
who so you
you just mentioned a lot so
is the trauma therapy because of
religious abuse or is it because of
sexual and physical abuse why is he
seeking trauma therapy and what does
that have to do with his
uber religious upbringing
so um
yes he's
one of four his um his the oldest is his
sister who is like they've told him
she's the star child she is the favorite
her grandkids
are everything and then he has a
then it's him jared
and then um
it's his
second younger brother who is autistic
and schizophrenic and then his baby
brother
and um
basically his sister ratted him out
um to get back into mom and dad's good
graces when he was like 21.
what did he do
he drank alcohol and got a tattoo
i know he's wild felicia
you are calling the wrong show honey
i got a lot of tattoos actually so
like uh-oh no you're good um okay so
that guy so
having a beer and having a tattoo got
him in trouble with his with his family
yes they kicked him out don't call don't
write don't text
don't do any of that um
he
tried to commit suicide
and
then it was like oh wait
we kind of love you but because you
don't
subscribe you're still on the outside so
i think he was never like hit or
he's like sexually physically abused but
i think there's well i know there's a
lot of like emotional absolutely yes
neglect kind of
he was always the odd one out okay um
yeah i mean even now
yeah
and it doesn't help that they live like
10 minutes away yeah yeah um so i'm
gonna tell you this up front okay
a cornerstone of his trauma therapy is
gonna be
cutting ties with his family for a
season if not forever
and something tells me that that's going
to be very challenging for him for you
and for your family unit
um
similar you can't um
you can't heal from addiction
if all of your friends still deal drugs
and you all share a house
or they all live 10 minutes away from
you
and so i want you to think of
trauma as it's not don't think of it as
the definition of trauma is
a series of things that happened that
overwhelm our body's response system
right it's like a tsunami it overwhelms
it
and
that usually comes in the not in the
form of these stories but it comes in
the form of our body remembering these
things it remembers the time the bear
attacked us
and chewed us up and we got away
and where trauma is really
it's impossible to heal from
when the bear keeps coming over to the
living room when the bear keeps coming
over and coming over and coming over so
these same people that heard him told
him really destructive misguided things
about what love looks like
love looks like get out of our lives if
you have a drink and a tattoo love looks
like god hates you love looks like you
do life like us or we hate you
that's that has wreaked havoc
on a well-functioning body on a
well-functioning psyche right
and so you're gonna have to at some
point break ties with that with that
crew for a while
something tells me that
he's still pretty entangled there um i
would
i would be surprised if them quote
unquote disowning him was the
the sole reason he tried to take his
life what was what was his suicide about
yeah it was right after that um
yeah he
he was
like
he was very sheltered so like taking
care of himself was like
he didn't know how to balance a
checkbook he didn't know he didn't know
like these basic things how to change
his oil when to change his oil and i
think
when i've talked to him about it it just
all became too much
and the fact that his parents just it
was like a little bit over a year after
they kicked him out
so they never allowed him to breathe and
all of a sudden they ripped away the
oxygen
and he
was never able to get his feet
underneath him and he just wanted that
to stop that hurt to stop okay
um
so
how do you factor into this are y'all
are married right
yes two years march 12th okay and um how
do you get along with his mom and dad
his sister i don't you don't okay cool
so
my parents um
live in san antonio also okay and
they've like really
just
accepted him loved him like we spend
most of our holidays with them
but there's
just this
he can't
he's very guarded of his family sure
absolutely and so what i want you to um
is gonna be hard for you because for you
that's not your family that's a couple
of people a couple of three or four
people that continually hurt your
husband
right
like they are evil to you because they
continually
beat up on your husband whether
psychologically you know what i mean and
so i want you to
be from this day forward don't say
another negative thing about them okay
at least for us until he's well until he
can be he can open be open about it okay
um you can tell him when he says hey i
need to go see mom and dad you can say
um
[Music]
are you doing well
is that a good idea for you today it's
not about them why would you go do that
they're the word nope it is i love you
and are you is that wise for you same as
my wife when i am at the drive-thru
of some
trashy establishment and i say
i would like a number
one with extra and she'll stop me to go
is that a wise choice right now
you know what i mean she's not saying
like you
she's just giving me one extra chance to
think about it right and sometimes i'm
like yeah you're right i'm an idiot and
i'll just say never mind can i have a
cup of coffee and then sometimes i'm
like yep i'm crashing into that brick
wall dude right
so let's lean more towards him okay and
this is going to be really hard for you
and i want you to make sure you hear
what i'm saying okay
don't take his healing as he enters
counseling don't take his healing as a
sign that he can't trust you
don't take his um silence or his
unwillingness to talk about stuff at the
beginning as a sign there's something
wrong with you or your relationship it's
really easy to take that sort of silence
personally
and right now as he goes into surgery
which is what trauma counseling is
um you wouldn't ask his surgeon who's
giving him knee surgery to go ahead and
cut your knees up too just because
this is his surgery and he needs you to
care for him when he gets out
and also make sure that he's got a safe
place to talk if and when he's ready
this means one important thing you have
to have somebody to talk to because it
might not be him for a season
okay do you have that
i do i recommend everybody who has a
spouse going to trauma counseling that
they go to some form of counseling or
have a close group of friends or one or
two people they meet with every single
week
because it's gonna feel really lonely
for a season
just for a season it's gonna feel really
lonely okay
so don't beat him up about not talking
to you don't take it personally
and i would really you hear me say this
all the time on the show and i know it's
like a broken record
give him a place to write
down things
whether you start to get a journal and
say as you enter this i want you to know
that i love you he's not going to always
be able to hear you but i want you to
write him notes and you leave that on
his pillow
and then he can write you back and leave
it on your pillow and it'll just be a
back and forth
um journal that you'll write together a
diary all right back and forth together
a letter writing y'all right back and
forth together and this will be a
monument to your to both of your healing
over the next however many years
okay
things in that journal will be like i
see you today
i want you to know that you're loved
your hug today allowed me to breathe a
little bit deeper
i know how hard you're working
or i miss you
you are absent today and i know that
you're somewhere hard and i want you to
know that i'm here and i love you that's
what i'm talking about in this thing
okay
had a funny memory of you today that
when we first started dating this
happened and it reminded me why i love
you so much
this isn't all pollyanna and all
positive it could be some dark stuff too
but i want him to not be able to here's
what people with trauma are good at
absorbing the good and dismissing it and
just scanning the environment for the
bad for the bad for the bad for the bad
because they've had to
he's waiting for you to leave him also
for him to do the one wrong thing that's
gonna kick it's gonna
make you hit the highway if you write it
down
he can't run from it he will see it over
and over and over again
hear what i'm saying
yes this becomes a critical thing
um
when does he start going to counseling
next week next week is the first big one
okay um does he want you to go with him
or does he want to do this by himself
um we've talked about like every now and
then maybe like a
joint like a you know the both of us
going but
for now it's just he wants to do it okay
i think if you get your own counselor
during the season two
after three four five weeks you invite
him to your session
and say i'd love for you to come visit
me
and that might be a session where you
can talk y'all can start learning new
languages as you're as you're moving
along here
he's gonna remember stuff that he hasn't
remembered in a long time he's gonna
walk this will be a hard season for both
of you
commit to staying anchored to him okay
okay do you promise oh yeah i can do
that i mean i just don't understand
like
the world is the worst place without him
so yeah there you go that's a and he
needs to hear you say that needs to read
you say that he needs to feel you
believe that
and that can be 30 second hugs to start
every day even this morning as i was
running out of the house my wife said i
haven't got my hug yet
and that wasn't her hug the hug was for
me
and so i stopped put everything down and
we got our 30-second hug in this morning
okay that's her making sure she didn't
say hey you look scattered today you
look like you're all over the place
again um what's going on overseas has
really done a number on me that that she
didn't bring up any of that stuff you
want to talk about it what are you
worried about she didn't do any of that
stuff
she just said i didn't get my hug this
morning
and i stopped and realized okay i know
what she's telling me i need to put my
phone down i need to stop scrolling i
need to i need to i need right so come
up with that with your language together
that way remind him that he's anchored
into you and y'all are anchored into
stone you're not going anywhere okay
um my promise to you is this
if he goes through this
you go through it and you'll do this
together as best you can
there is a big
beautiful future on the back end of this
for y'all
this is legacy change this is changing
family trees this is him having the
courage to stand up and say i will not
put my kids through this i will not put
my wife through this i will not put me
through this anymore
this is owning what comes next hey hang
on the line here i'm going to send you
guys a copy of my new book own your past
change your future y'all can read this
together
it's going to parallel his journey it's
going to give you all some things to
talk about together
and you can read a chapter you can read
it together you can read it he can read
it
and then you can say what do you think
about that chapter it gives you an entry
point into a conversation or he might
say ah that chapter's full of crap or he
might say
you should go read chapter this because
that one really spoke to me um and then
it gives you all some play-by-play on
what to do on the back end of this deal
i'm excited for this journey all about
to go on it is going to be hard
don't take it personal but stay
connected god he's lucky to have you
felicia
and so
as the great cube once said bye felicia